hola y gracias por acompañarnos una
europa todavía confinada en plena
campaña de vacunación y con tensiones
externas pero también con separatismos
internos antes de encontrarnos con
maggie brno para nuestro debate entre
eurodiputados con public senna nos
reunimos con un representante europeo
fuera de lo común es la figura central
de los independentistas catalanes ahora
que en cataluña se llevarán a cabo
elecciones regionales en plena pandemia
el 14 de febrero
bienvenido carles puigdemont usted fue
presidente de la generalitat de cataluña
en 2016
de hecho organizó en octubre de 2017 un
referendo de autodeterminación ilegal
según el poder en madrid que se saldó
con una victoria del sí pero apenas con
un 43% de participación y nueve
dirigentes secesionistas fueron entonces
encarcelados y condenados a penas que
van hasta los 13 años de reclusión pero
usted no porque se refugió en bélgica
justamente para huir de esa justicia
española
los procesos judiciales también le
impidieron ocupar un escaño en el
parlamento europeo durante seis meses
después de su elección
retomó sus funciones hace un año
entretanto el parlamento europeo lanzó
la examinación de la petición del
levantamiento de la inmunidad
parlamentaria hecha por las autoridades
españolas que pronto votaran plenarias
sobre este tema y es cierto que a menudo
este levantamiento de la inmunidad es
aceptado le preocupa que pronto haya un
levantamiento de inmunidad para usted y
una extradición hacia españa
adicional españa
primero que todo gracias por invitarme
normalmente no hay muchas posibilidades
de ganar este levantamiento de la
inmunidad pero luchamos para decirle a
nuestros colegas que se trata de una
persecución política es evidente que es
una persecución política entonces no hay
razón para levantar la inmunidad fuimos
elegidos miembros del parlamento europeo
por la misma razón por la cual estamos
siendo perseguidos pero finalmente si
perdemos este levantamiento de la
inmunidad lucharemos primero ante la
justicia belga y en particular
llegaremos hasta luxemburgo a la corte
europea de justicia y silvia y se
decidirá si se trata o no de un caso de
persecución política en todo caso
dijimos que iríamos a europa a
defendernos porque hay un marco legal
que nos permite defender nuestras
libertades nuestros derechos
algo que no es posible en españa así que
después de tres años y tres meses de
represión de exilio estamos aquí en el
parlamento europeo luchando en realidad
no por nuestros derechos personales es
el derecho de más de un millón de
personas que votaron por nosotros
pero precisamente carles puigdemont
usted es un eurodiputado que ocupa un
escaño desde hace un año como lo decía
se siente involucrado en ese mandato
europeo porque usted decidió encabezar
la lista de su nuevo partido y de hecho
estaba molesto con el antiguo en las
elecciones catalanas se tiene la
impresión de que realmente solo importa
cataluña para usted o bruselas también
un poco se la comen
normalmente cataluña se parte de la
unión europea somos en realidad siete
millones y medio de ciudadanos europeos
más de 2.300.000 ciudadanos europeos
participaron en el referendo y fueron
golpeados y perseguidos por la policía
española entonces se trata de un tema
europeo también los derechos
fundamentales las libertades de
expresión el derecho a la
autodeterminación es un tema europeo que
no sólo le compete a los catalanes sino
también a los europeos entonces porque
se presenta a usted como cabeza de lista
en cataluña recién entrado al parlamento
si me presento pero dije que no sería
cándida
la elección de la presidencia de
cataluña voy a respaldar mi proyecto voy
a respaldar a nuestra candidata a la
elección de la presidencia laura borrás
voy a demostrar que nuestra lucha es la
misma aunque debamos hacer política en
europa porque en realidad el único lugar
donde puedo hacer política es en el
parlamento europeo porque es
absolutamente imposible hacer algo en
españa incluso aunque ganemos las
elecciones voy a demostrar ese respaldo
porque empezamos el proceso de
independencia es un proceso largo y
claro está lleno de incertidumbres pero
es un proceso que ya empezó y que debe
terminarse de manera democrática y
debemos luchar por eso no es fácil pero
debemos aprovechar todas las
oportunidades para hacer política entre
tanto las elecciones son organizadas en
plena pandemia de coronavirus con
asesores que harán falta en los puestos
de votación para controlar y con un
riesgo de baja participación sirven de
algo
usted tiene toda la razón quizás no sea
lo más sabio hacer elecciones en medio
de esta pandemia sobre todo en cataluña
y sobre todo en españa' que tal vez es
la más afectada con la peor situación
pero de nuevo fue la decisión de la
justicia española quiero recordar que
las últimas elecciones hace tres años
fueron convocadas de manera ilegal por
el gobierno español no tenía el poder de
hacerlo y ahora aunque el gobierno
catalán había decidido convocar estas
elecciones después de esta campaña de
vacunación a finales del mes de mayo
la justicia española dijo no hay que
hacerlo ahora usted tiene razón pero no
podemos hacer nada en contra de eso
6 dirección del partido socialista de
que se tenemos dicho eso para estas
elecciones el partido socialista
encabezado por el antiguo ministro de
salud salvador y allá catalán y catalán
until independista va viento en popa
como explica que el señor illa vaya
viento en popa está bajando el interés
por el independentismo
es que en vez de portland y bautismo
y si siempre ha estado esta idea un poco
extraña de creer que el ministro de
salud de españa que gestiono tal vez de
la peor manera la pandemia en españa las
cifras están ahí los datos están allí es
uno de los elementos del gobierno
español mejor valorados por la población
es increíble pero es así debo decir que
todas las encuestas se equivocaron hace
tres años todas las encuestas se
equivocaron ahora tiene sentido que por
lo general el partido socialista puede
encabezar las encuestas pero la realidad
siempre es más importante y mostrará que
esa realidad que se ve con cada elección
la mayoría del parlamento catalán está a
favor de la independencia de cataluña
eso es indiscutible y paul evans catalán
durán de pantallas de la catalana ya se
han contrastado usted encabeza la lista
de juntos por cataluña ha considerado de
centroderecha independentista pero como
lo dijo tiene previsto de eclipsarse
detrás de laura borràs
la presidencia de la generalitat según
los rumores ustedes tendrían un plan
común el mismo día de la constitución
del parlamento los diputados
independentistas votarían una resolución
parlamentaria que reivindica la
soberanía del pueblo catalán de nuevo
una acción unilateral y sus aliados
tradicionales la izquierda
independentista moderada esquerra
republicana y los separatistas radicales
no están nada entusiasmados siguen muy
divididos
hay divisiones es cierto pero no en los
temas más importantes es decir en cuanto
a una cataluña independiente una
república independiente por supuesto eso
dependerá de la voluntad de los
ciudadanos si hay un mensaje en las
urnas que dice claramente que más del
50% de las voces están a favor de la
independencia de cataluña mire el
parlamento son los representantes de la
voluntad del pueblo no se puede hacer
algo distinto debemos escuchar y decir
hay una mayoría de catalanes que quiere
proceder entonces debemos plantear este
tema hay donde debe ser planteado es
decir ante las instituciones no ante la
corte de justicia en el debate
parlamentario y hablar de ello
intercambiando puntos de vista entre los
que están a favor de la independencia y
los que están en contra de la
independencia
todos somos catalanes queremos lo mejor
para nuestro país
sí pero los que están a favor de la
independencia señor cuya montes desde el
principio no están de acuerdo sobre el
método nunca están de acuerdo sobre el
método para obtener la independencia no
volverá a ocurrir lo mismo esta vez
aunque glück
insisto si el resultado es claro
tendremos el deber de actuar de manera
unitaria el problema que hemos tenido
estos tres años es que la represión es
real la represión tuvo efectos que
dividieron un poco la estrategia
independentista
pero cuando estuvimos juntos pudimos
ganar todos los combates y si la
voluntad de la mayoría de los catalanes
es clara para continuar por ese camino
nuestro deber como representantes de esa
población que es actuar en consecuencia
y por supuesto hablar de ello y decirle
al estado español mire a pesar de su
fórmula fracasaron porque todavía hay
una mayoría tal vez más sólida que nunca
a favor de la independencia entonces hay
que cambiar y decir es el momento de
hacer lo que se hizo en escocia hace
unos años organizar un referendo y si no
tenemos el derecho tenemos el derecho de
decidir nuestro futuro
precisamente usted menciona escocia y
las consecuencias
hecho consecuencia del break sheets
salida de gran bretaña de la unión
europea es que refuerza a los
independentistas escoceses que adoran a
la unión europea
el snp quiere organizar un referéndum
sin el acuerdo de londres que es
indispensable eso es similar a un
escenario que usted ya vivió les
aconseja este unilateralismo que no tuvo
muy buenos resultados para ustedes si me
permite decirlo
bueno pero no es lo mismo porque estoy
convencido de que el reino unido no es
españa la tradición democrática del
reino unido incluso aunque no haya un
acuerdo con el gobierno escocés será
respetada no tengo ninguna duda sobre
eso sobre la voluntad democrática
democrática esa es la gran diferencia
entre el estado español y gran bretaña
porque el estado español ni siquiera
quiere hablar del tema incluso aunque
somos 65 o 75 por ciento de catalanes a
favor de la independencia no quiere
hablar del tema
ese no es el caso del reino unido- y
estoy convencido de que escocia se
volverá un estado independiente un
estado de la unión europea mire cuando
hicieron el primer referendo hubo esta
campaña del miedo que decía si se salen
del reino unido se saldrán de la unión
europea y ahora no son independientes y
no están en la unión europea entonces el
mensaje es claro hay que dejar que las
personas decidan de manera democrática
esa es la gran diferencia detrás la
situación en reino unido y la situación
en españa
en españa'
pasemos ahora a asuntos más europeos que
preocupan mucho al conjunto de los
europeos en su país 70 por ciento de
personas vacunadas es el objetivo de su
primer ministro pedro sánchez socialista
para activar un regreso progresivo a la
normalidad para volver a recibir
turistas extranjeros un objetivo que
debería cumplirse antes del final del
verano de 2021 a fin de cuentas cree
usted que la pandemia se manejó de
manera satisfactoria en españa'
un lugar limón españa
para tumbar a nada realmente la gestión
de la pandemia desde el punto de vista
sanitario fue una catástrofe pero sobre
todo desde el punto de vista económico
fue todavía peor que hace unos días creo
que hace una semana el banco central
europeo publicó los datos oficiales del
impacto sobre el pib de los esfuerzos
financieros económicos realizados por
los estados para ayudar a combatir los
efectos de la crisis económica y españa
fue el peor es el peor de los estados
europeos y el impacto sanitario es
inmenso en nuestro país y sobre todo en
un sector que representa bastante de
nuestro pib el sector de servicios y
concretamente de turismo que es
increíble que no haya recursos
económicos para los restaurantes para
los hoteles para las actividades
relacionadas con el turismo que no
tienen suficiente dinero para continuar
con sus actividades cuando se levante la
restricción debemos ser muy exigentes
porque se dedicó mucho dinero europeo
para españa'
no estamos para nada satisfechos somos
realmente muy críticos de la gestión del
presidente de gobierno español ante las
consecuencias de la crisis
español
todo el mundo es un poco crítico de la
gestión de estas autoridades porque esa
campaña de vacunación es complicada ha
habido 500.000 muertes por coronavirus
en europa la presidenta de la comisión
reconoció el 10 de febrero delante de su
parlamento europeo las deficiencias de
la vacunación sin embargo esta comisión
encargó a su nombre 2700 millones de
vacunas y declaró que es prudente sobre
la autorización de estas vacunas por
razones sanitarias la comisión considera
que son los fabricantes los que no
pusieron en práctica todos los medios de
producción y que son los mayores
culpables quien tiene la razón
yo soy absorban con la comisión cadena
y estoy absolutamente convencido de que
la comisión europea fracasó en su
voluntad honesta de hecho de asegurar la
vacunación para una gran mayoría de la
población a corto plazo
es necesario reconocerlo también hay una
cierta cacofonía entre la o ms la
comisión europea los productores los
estados otros estados que impulsaron
otras vacunas hay una cacofonía que no
esclarece para nada lo que se debe hacer
hay un mensaje confuso que provoca
confusiones sobre los que en realidad
son las víctimas de esto los ciudadanos
desafortunadamente la unión europea
perdió una oportunidad para liderar a
nivel mundial esta campaña de vacunación
pero en realidad agradezco que la señora
von der leyen haya reconocido un poco
ese fracaso ese error
foto usted también le hizo un llamado al
jefe de la diplomacia europea el español
josep borrell para que renunciara pero
se trata de un viejo enemigo político
recordemos lógico es un catalán
antiindependentista tienen más peso eso
sobre su juicio que su desafortunada
visita a moscú
no no en realidad desde el comienzo de
nuestra intervención la primera
intervención dijimos que los dobles
estándares europeos eran los que
amenazaban la credibilidad europea sin
importar si se trata del señor borrell
quien independientemente es anti
independentista y cataluña hace tres
años dijo que era necesario desinfectar
cataluña pero eso no importa es un
problema de la unión europea no se puede
recomendar una fórmula a los demás que
no aplica para uno mismo
mire hace unos días la ong fuimos que
trata de denunciar la persecución de los
artistas y acaba de decir que españa es
el peor país del mundo que tiene la
mayor cantidad de artistas que han sido
perseguidos o encarcelados entonces se
trata de la unión europea no es un
problema de josep borrell en moscú es un
problema de la unión europea busco
cuando hay evidentes violaciones de los
derechos fundamentales en la unión
europea callarse y de hecho ir a otros
países donde es necesario exigir el
respeto de los derechos humanos
algo que debe hacerse con una voz sólida
fuerte que desafortunadamente la unión
europea no puede garantizar justamente a
causa del historial de español
gracias por haber sido nuestro invitado
y carles puigdemont gracias a ustedes
por habernos acompañado quédense con
nosotros para más información hasta muy
pronto
[Música]